every day humans make dozens of
judgments from deciding whether our
clothes match to determining whether a
shady character in the street is a
threat such decisions aren't based on
hard and fast rules a new study reveals
instead our concept of threat and even
of the color blue is all relative to
make the fine researchers showed non
colorblind participants a series of a
thousand dots ranging from very blue to
very purple and acent the judge whether
each dot was blue for the first two
hundred trials participants saw an equal
number of dots from the blue and purple
parts of the spectrum but then the
prevalence of blue dots gradually
decreased to just a fraction of what it
was before by the end of the study
participants interpretation of the
colors had changed dots that they'd
thought were purple in the first set of
trials they now classified as blue that
is their concept of the color blue had
expanded to also include shades of
purple even when the researchers
forewarned participants that blue dots
would become rarer and promised the
money if they kept their judgments
consistent the same shift occurred and
the team found similar results in more
complex versions of the task where
participants had to judge whether a face
was threatening or if a research
proposal was ethical when threatening
faces became less common people started
to consider previously benign examples
as posing a threat these results could
explain why so many people tend to be
pessimistic about the state of the world
as common problems become rare
previously minor issues start to seem
much more problematic
[Music]